do you think that was a successful move
given the state of the world as it is
um
i don't know how to respond to that
do you think people are happier do you
think they're more fulfilled do you
think they have the same level of
purpose as they did 60 years ago
uh no they don't because oh my god this
is like it's another complicated message
um because before they used to have a
lot of discipline into that so they will
they will have a list of things they
will have to follow in order to be a
good father or to be a good wife and
have kids and a solid family and values
that we don't have anymore because
there's too much freedom now
so so then wouldn't that kind of
contradict what you said like aren't
rules somewhat good yes okay church-wise
because you're saying in general right
i'm saying okay in
general in the population i think
there's now there's too many rules
everything is too free there's too much
freedom now so people are getting more
weak you can also feel like i'm mental
health uh people can do too much now i
don't have a guidance anymore but at the
same time church at least what do you
want to see in italy i don't agree with
that i don't respect that
because
church always like have people believing
in that but most like they they get
people that are lost they don't have any
they're easy to indoctrinate that's what
it to me personally that's what it is
because there's more like more
worshiping type of thing more than
you're free to believe in what you want
and as long as you're a good person and
you're good with the other people as god
actually was saying right that's what
it's supposed to be about right but i
don't know i just don't like the church
and the way the past so that has to
get all these people there and more more
time is just people that learn loss no
self-esteem
create sad or yeah let's go ahead to be
honest
it's really it's complicated things it's
a hospital
you go there
people
the reason why you you will see a lot of
people who are broken and hurt is
because that's where they're going to
heal for me what got me more connected
to church because i used to go to church
with my mom
and it's like i'm just going for the
sake of going with her i wasn't getting
anything from it like the word like i'm
hearing the pot pastor preach
it just was i was not retaining it i had
to find god for my own self find my own
church i went from to several churches
but i wasn't comfortable until i found
the one that i'm at now okay and
being there here in the world
it helped it healed me in a way because
when you do go to church you're not
going to go there perfect or anything
you're going to find people a lot of
broken people and already if your mental
health is not 100 there you can't think
for yourself and you have a pastor that
is
not
necessarily teaching from the bible is
adding his own
knowledge to it and kind of controlling
the congregation that's where it's bad
but i still believe there are good
churches there i'm at one now because
they are big on you knowing god for
yourself having that own relationship
with god and don't worship us you need
to read that bible for yourself you may
hear us preach it's your own
you have to take that responsibility to
go back do your own research on that
word that they've preached and then
yeah you can take it from there don't
let them control you so i have a
question do you think um a lot of guys
will talk about how they really doubt
like women in church like the
authenticity of them because they happen
to come to church at like 28 29 when
time's running out and they've been ran
through do you think that's a fair
critique not necessarily
because because it's like it's just kind
of convenient like right when you need a
husband now you're at church yeah like
that's like that's that's crazy now
you're sorry that's wild
that's wild i go to quite a fairly a
young church there's a lot of youth
there yeah so there's different parts to
a church there's like the youth and then
there's the oh no yeah i understand
there's different parts i understand
it's not everybody but i've seen the
trend
i've seen like like i talked to i've
been to like many different churches
because i've moved around a lot there's
a trend it's like between twenty six-ish
i can't speak on that because my one is
there's quite a lot of young people so i
don't i can't speak on that but
i would say there's a lot of people my
age that have been run through like even
me the reason for me going to church is
i was living a lifestyle that i wasn't
happy with and i know that i've still
got time on my hands because my pastor
does preach that he's just like you
can't expect to come to church at 35
where you should have changed your life
now so that's why it's important to know
god from a young age because it's like
you have different seasons and if you
miss one season it can set you back like
10 years do you think that keeps women
single though because they preach for
women to wait till they're married and
you're basically saying telling like you
let the last guy hit it for free and
then you're saying oh you have to marry
me in order to have sex so you don't you
don't think and then like on top of that
there's only
30 maybe 20 men in the church so it's
not even
and it's like you're asking men to wait
when you let the last five guys go for
free not necessarily
so that it
again it goes down to you knowing god
for yourself having a relationship with
god and in that time god will speak to
you men will come to you because you
will be tempted i've been in church and
i'm not going to lie and say i was
perfect
i was still having sex for quite some
time whilst i was at church
that that's just because my inner self
was not ready right but you're talking
about you so i'm talking from like a
man's point but so so what i'm saying is
honest i'm saying because that's one
thing
and i i appreciate that like that's
that's but i'm saying like from a guy's
point of view like why would he wait
when the last guy's got it for free
because men because men value purity
that's why it's good to have somebody
that's on the same level as you so for
example now i know that i'm on this
this journey of sex
it's not 50 50. so i'm saying like there
aren't enough men in the church for the
women so like they're not you can't say
like oh we should all wait because
they're not there i'm not saying wait
because you can still go out and speak
to guys but you kind of have to use
discernment and know that okay i have to
go for a guy that's ready to wait for me
to get me so that's why you have to be
wise when you're dating but to me like
what i'm saying is like i think that
keeps women single because i don't think
there's a lot of guys that are willing
to do that because it's like
no but i think that the the real thing
is like it's like you made your bed lie
in it and if you want it if you want it
i mean it's if we want to live in a
fantasy world
where all these guys guys are dying to
wait for born again virgins but they're
not
but they're not even gay women will
remain single because it's like there's
no hope like you you don't say that i
was a hoe let me just continue being her
then because there's no chance of me
getting a good guy let's start that's
that's already ready to wait well i
think again
i see what pearl's saying i think if you
do go to church and
[Music]
you have been run through before
you know
don't just put up blockers because
you've just started going to church but
like because i see your point right you
you've waited so late in the day to
change your whole whole life and when i
was helping people online there was a
lady that i came across that over her
name nameless and she shared a whole
pass with me and it was exactly what
you're talking about
she had a really promiscuous past and
then she found god
and
she didn't she said to me i haven't been
with a man since and if i meet someone
i'll be with him but i see your point
because from a male perspective it does
feel like you're getting the wrong end
of the deal you know yeah because it's a
bad deal yeah and that's and the church
tells men to take that
they they do you can't even get a man in
the church anyway yeah you really can't
get a man in the church and so like on
top of that there's you're right there's
there's not the men there so even if we
had it all the girls or all the men got
married in the church like there still
would be twenty percent oh there's still
a be what
like forty percent of the women they're
still single that's why they date
outside yeah that's why they on a dating
website and
live living a completely different life
to them going to church
and that's what's happening but if i'm a
christian and i'm dating a guy i'm going
to bring him to church
you have to somehow but
if he's willing to come if he's willing
to come he'd be willing to do a lot so
that's why on my first day or when i'm
communicating with a guy i said i'll
tell him this is what i'm a christian
this is what i want
and then if he is willing to come and
i can't i'll pray on it there'll be
signs where i'll see that okay this guy
is just trying to see if he can hit
do you get what i'm saying
but all men want to hit it that's like
all men want sex i i think there's
actually
like to add on to this
if there's any lady watching this and
she thinks church is the answer i
actually would flip it on its head and
think
where are guys going to be and where
they're going to be the most respectful
i've been in martial arts gyms my whole
life and i've never met a more
respectful set of men in my whole life
and they are predominantly filled with
men
so
to me it's like go
create leverage for yourself
like
it's funny so i should join a martial
arts gym yeah
no you should i'm i'm being serious and
they are
they can protect you
right you know that already because
they're in a martial arts gym they are
the most respect some of the most
respectful guys you will ever meet in
your life you think they're going to be
violent and all of this they are not
they they are the the some of the least
violent people i've ever met but the
thing the thing is with the church like
they'll have a guy that has all the
qualities that a girl is looking for but
if he he says i don't want to go to
church i'm never going to go to church
they say to turn that down
and it's like okay well then die alone
like i see that that's the thing i find
hard about
religion in general yeah is
the you could have
almost the perfect match but because
they don't sign up to your
rules
that you then you can't um marry them
and i think i think it's one thing if
you're a virgin like i think you can ask
more and you're like more competitive in
the church but it's like if you if
you're not like what why would a church
guy date you um yeah it's true like it's
not in the bible
you can't judge another person who are
you to judge yeah but
at the end of the day like if you really
are in tune with god you can't judge
another person based off their lifestyle
but you can't basically experience you
can make that you can't it was my
weakness your weakness could be
something else so i have to accept that
and understand that that was you that
was your past so that's a lot another
thing that i noticed about now today's
society is that people are so fixated on
somebody's past that was my because
because that's because you're looking at
this from a woman's point of view like
when you think you're thinking from a
woman not a man men care about a woman's
past women care about a man's future and
that's what i'm talking about so i'm
saying like like they might not they
might say don't judge but i'm sorry your
actions say something about who you are
so so if i was with a guy that for 10
years was a drug dealer i'm sorry it's
not bad a bad thing to say hmm that
might not be a good husband and so if a
guy wants to say hey she was a hoe for
this many years like
that's not going to be a good wife i
should go pick the pretty virgin down
the street like i think that's fair i
don't think that's judgmental i just
think that's your bed
um can i say something go ahead
certainly if i had the past which i feel
no one should like be defined from you
your past past actions anyway
nor a guy that goes to church should not
follow the judgmental mindset because
everyone got passed
but personally i would lie i was like
yes i'm a very jane i'll get surgery
down there
and that's another thing i was gonna i
would never say that you would never
find that period you can't do that
but people do like a lot of women do you
like who have had a past life when when
it got lost
yeah but the thing is like guys aren't
dumb over a certain age like i'm sorry
if the girls come on like i've had girls
on the show and they're like 25 26 27.
as many of you know i was just banned on
tick-tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible